bonjour parce que vous parle de choses
sérieuses mais qu'on ne se prend pas au
sérieux parce que rire c'est bon pour la
santé on va vous parler du festival de
l'humour
bienvenue sur 9 7 4 tv pour nous en
parler deux artisans on va dire de ce
festival
bonjour messieurs bonjour alors le sait
le grand rue de même fait ça bien mais
ça c'est le grand retour du festival
l'humour oui tout à fait c'est le retour
du festival de l'humour pour la a connu
pendant 16 ans il ya ces trente
dernières années qui a marqué le paysage
réunionnais on s'est rendu compte que
pendant que l'absence du festival de
l'humour
la relève a eu fallait les nouveaux les
nouveaux humoristes ont eu du mal
justement à trouver un lieu pour
s'exprimer et et ont d'une certaine
manière cette relève elle est toujours
en devenir
ea n'a pas pu s'affirmer comme on puisse
affirmer les acteurs du de l'humour du
passé que ce soit les studios rivière
que ce soit alors vous l'avez remarqué
voulait constater on est dans le hall il
était à départementaux pascal montrouge
pourquoi c'est une nouvelle
collaboration
ma part ce que le monde évolue et
heureusement on est toujours à l écoute
de
monde et qui plus est du monde
artistique et comme le disait très
justement il vend moi ce qui m'intéresse
en tout cas dans le projet que je peux
défendre pour les théâtres
départementaux
c'est aussi là relève c'est aussi les
jeunes et on a comme on a lancé par
exemple cette année un label qui
s'appelle fourmis grand galop pour les
tout tout tout tout jeune auteur aux
jeunes écrivains et auteurs la même
chose là de se dire comment on peut
soutenir aider cette nouvelle génération
qui sont des gens de talent mais il ya
aussi quelque chose qui est important
c'est que c'est avant tout des comédiens
qui sont sur le plateau et je pense par
exemple à daniel léocadie qui est
maintenant à un acteur qui joue dans des
pièces dites sérieuses et qui a commencé
par l'humour ou comme laurent robert qui
aujourd'hui est à la comédie française
pour le roméo et juliette qui joue en ce
moment et qui vient par exemple des
comics cool qu'on avait programmé à 6
ans donc tout ça pour dire que sas après
préfigurer ça prépare aussi à une
nouvelle génération d'artistes avant
toute chose
alors bonsoir tout le monde comment ça
va nous sommes en direct du théâtre de
champ fleuri avec alexandre gilles à la
caméra olivier avec son tee shirt et son
ton dal ont fait mieux
tout de suite je vous demande d'accueil
le premier artiste de la soirée
brigitte mais bon une expression connue
la réunion à part entière entièrement à
part est-ce qu'on peut rire de tout à la
réunion dans ce contexte là est ce que
est ce que justement ce les gens
viennent voir cet humour là on peut rire
de tout on peut retomber attendons donc
là où c'est plus difficile c'est quand
même par la région d'un des assauts et
des autres on
l'anil as fait ton carthage qatar donc
ça c'est la voie royale pour l'humour
par contre l'humour il ya différents
types d'humour il ya une gestuelle des
nouveaux nominés de l'humour en stand up
qui était mon entrée particulier à la
réunion on a on a cette spécificité de
justement d'utiliser le terrain donc
c'est un moment particulier est-ce que
c'est plus facile pour les spectateurs
vient voir du théâtre via voir en
concert
est-ce qu'on tous les portes pour
l'humour oui bien sûr nous on le voit
bien avec des artistes consacré qui font
des fans qui sont à 37 x 2,3 soir à
champ fleuri
par contre l'humour cette nouvelle
génération jour où seront invités à
venir les découvrir c'est à dire que
vous avez sur une soirée 2 duo
vous découvrez 45 minutes de chaque
spectacle ou trois spectacles 30 minutes
de charge spectacle ce qu'on veut
vraiment fait c'est que ce soit celle de
l'humour soit la possibilité à ces à ces
nouveaux artistes qui s'installe qui
existe depuis 20 de 3 à 5 ans pour
certains puisque ça tu connais aussi ma
philosophie pour ses théâtres là en tant
que directeur ce qui m'importe avant
tout chose c'est la qualité et la
qualité elle peut être au niveau de la
danse du théâtre dit sérieux ou de
classiques ou de l'humour du spectacle
jeune public c'est vraiment avoir tout
une question de qualité et je pense que
le public
là on parle de théâtre populaire dans sa
globalité je parle pas que du festival
de l'humour
le théâtre populaire il est là pour ça
pour un moment donné nous rencontrer un
public et à partir du moment où il ya
véritablement de la qualité et c'est ça
qui fait la différence c'est juste un
tous les âges tout le monde
malheureusement le théâtre pour tout le
monde
en tout cas une occasion c'est bien ici
dans les théâtres départementaux vous
ayez compris il ya beaucoup d'énergie
pour vous faire plaisir
alors n'hésitez pas à pousser les portes
du théâtre et à bientôt si on essaie de
call tv
merci messieurs